John: Good morning Hank, it's Monday.
You know what that means: special bonus video!
Coming to you in 4 parts.
Part 1: Europe.
So Hank, next week I will be on whirlwind
tour of Europe with my wife and a couple of
my friends.
On Tuesday, June 16 we will be in Berlin for
an event that is unfortunately currently sold
out.
But nerdfighters of Germany, I will let you
know on Twitter if more tickets become available,
and regardless I hope that you enjoy "Margos
Spuren."
My German is excellent, I know.
Then on Wednesday I will be in Paris meeting
and greeting people outside of a bookstore,
more info in the dooblydoo.
And on Thursday I will be in London at a place
and time yet to be determined.
The appropriate twitter feeds to find out
more are all in the dooblydoo, but it is starting
to happen Hank, the Paper Towns movie is starting
to become real.
Part 2: Our podcast.
Hank, our new podcast "Dear Hank and John"
or as I like to think of it, "Dean John and
Hank," has made its debut on iTunes and SoundCloud.
Links below.
This week we discuss whether bowling can heal
the broken human heart, whether people have
peed on every square inch of earth.
And of course we have all the latest news
from Mars, which is a cold dead rock in the
lifeless vacuum of space, and AFC Wimbledon,
the most important soccer team in the history
of the universe.
Part 3: the United States of America.
Hank, Nat and Cara and I will also be touring
in the US in July, but I can't tell you where
specifically because I don't yet know.
We will be visiting the states that get the
most votes over at papertownsmovie.com/tour.
There you can vote for your state by liking
and reblogging on tumblr.
One tumblr note equals one vote.
And we will visit the places that get the
most votes between now and June 15.
Hank, I'm just gonna be honest with you, I'm
rooting for Indiana and Montana, although
I will also accept any other outcome.
Part 4: the decoupling of wages and productivity.
That's what people really want to hear about
in bonus videos.
So Hank, in your last video you were like:
Hank: And I also worry about the decoupling
of productivity and wages.
John: As it happens, that's something that
I also spend a lot of time thinking about.
So as you can tell from this graph, since
World War II wages and productivity were really
closely correlated until about 2000, when
there was this great decoupling.
And ever since then productivity has surged
but wages have remained stagnant.
This is a big part of why we've seen this
dramatic increase in the disparity of wealth
in the United States in the last, like 20
years.
These days the richest 1% of Americans control
about 40% of America's total wealth.
And that's bad.
Not just morally bad, it's also economically
and socially bad.
Decreasing economic mobility means that, on
average, the most talented and innovative
people are less likely to get the opportunities
they need to create new businesses and make
lots of jobs, and etc.
But anyway Hank, that graph only goes back
to 1947.
If you go back much further, say to the industrial
revolution, you see a similar decoupling between
productivity and wages which this economist
Robert Allen calls the Engel's Pause.
And the Engel's Pause lasted several decades
until wages suddenly shot up, and it's possible
I guess that we're in the middle of another
Engel's Pause, because we are having this,
like, technological revolution, right?
But it's also possible that something entirely
different is happening because the sample
size of history is tiny!
Like, Hank, for almost all of the last 10,000
years, pretty much everyone's job was either
farmer or hunter/gatherer.
It's only in like the last 300 years that
lots and lots of people have even had these
non-farm jobs that people associate with 'wages.'
And that lack of historical precedence is
a big part of the reason I feel skeptical
towards pretty much anyone who expresses confidence
when it comes to fiscal policy or economic
history.
In short, Hank, I think wealth inequality
is one of the biggest issues facing the United
States and I think we should be very worried
about the decoupling of wages and productivity,
but we also need to remember that we are in
the middle of history and we can collectively
decide whether this decreasing economic mobility
is permanent.
Of course, I might be wrong.
The possibility that you might be wrong is
the very definition of economics.
Hank, nerdfighters, I'd love to hear more
of your thoughts on this.
In the mean time don't forget to vote for
your state at papertownsmovie.com/tour, link
in the dooblydoo.
And I hope to see as many of you as possible
next week in Europe.
Hank, you will see me tomorrow.